thanks for staying and thank for the
talk I think this talk will be uh a
little bit related to the talks we had
privacy but this is an example of
sometimes we might not you know be able
to do some causal analysis so we use
some correlation analysis to tackle this
problem but in the end I will tell you
in it sometimes we need to try our best
to create a simulations system that we
could you know provide a better inside
so I am Su Chan principal data scientist
in papso
um the beginning I would like to give
you a very quick overview of uh Pepsi
Ecom um so you I think most of you or
some of you might have experient
purchase a bag of layers or Mountain Dew
or Pepsi Zero in one of the platform
amazon.com
instacart uh our team is the engine
behind all this orders and
operations we are responsible for
managing and delivering over 180
products to more than 30 customers and
our business across sales supply chain
finance and of course marketing and data
science machine learning with
engineering team we laid a robust
foundation for a streamlined and data
driven operations and this project is
one of the uh very interesting project
we collaborated with our marketing
team as a e-commerce business our
marketing strategy are across entral
around uh digital platforms uh take
amazon.com as an example we have three
main products sponsor search which is
when you search a brand or product you
will see this tag sponsored showing up
and uh you might see this product in the
top of ranking and we have sponsor brand
or banners and display ads among all
three products we spend almost 85% of
spending on the uh sponsor search so
this is our main channel to reach our
consumer and like many marketers we are
trying to answer this very simple but
tricky question how much sales is
actually driven by our marketing
investment right this question is hard
to answer because such data points are
usually hard to collect or um biased
right so marketing typically will rely
on attributed sales or attributed return
um attributed returns this uh metric um
is usually inflating the actual sales or
actual traffic driven by your marketing
spending so we wanted to be able to
decompose or to be able to measure the
incrementality from uh our
sales and besides we also wanted to see
what is the different drivers in our
business driving our uh sales and we
wanted to be able to uh break it down
into bucket to bucket and hopefully to
optimize our budget allocation and
possibly in the future predict ourselves
under changing scenario so basically we
wanted to come in from the top with a
lot of message signal and in down some
well explained waterful
chge and Tackle this problem is similar
to answer causal Pro uh questions and in
in the past or in Practical there are
two type of approach one is a purely
rely on historical data right you could
do some causal inference causal analysis
you could do some attribution model or
building some correlation model like M
marketing mix modeling or you could
collect some new data by launching some
randomized um uh experiments right like
AB testing so you could measure okay if
I do this how much sales I get if I do
that how much sales i
g and what and in our project in our uh
um uh effort we opt for the mmm approach
but what is exactly is mmn so marketing
mix modeling is a statistical technique
that can quantify the different impacts
of your marketing inputs on sales or
other performance metric you wanted to
evaluate so if we put it in a
mathematical way it's basically set up a
correlation analysis between your cells
or your metrics Target variable and your
marketing variables your impressions
your
spending and other the control variable
you wanted to consider let's say sity
weather promotions Supply chains
microeconomics ex right and we usually
build the regression want to F
regression model or software regression
model and typically mm will try to
decompose this total celles into two
bucket while Bas sales which says uh
without any changing of all the control
variable you're thinking or marketing
effect you're thinking what is the
actual sales you are expecting and we
have another part is incremental sales
which can be attributed by different
drivers so now the question is why right
like we have so many tools why we
finally landed up here um of course
other are really powerful and uh take
randomized experiment as example it's
usually a gold standard if you wanted to
answer some causal problems right but in
Practical there are a lot of constraints
for example um it's almost invasible for
us to launch experiment for each of our
180 products and uh sometimes what some
Big Brand you would assume the signal
from your campaign might be super weak
like we might uh we might expect only
one or two% of the leave uh sales leave
on a big Rand and which means you need
to collect a lot of samples be able to
have some significance tests uh for your
experiment right and we also need to
think about opportunity cost if you turn
off some of a mark marketing commit for
a while you might lose the share uh
during the
competitions and the same issue might uh
happen in potential outcomes analysis um
if you think about the data um if you
business this data based on weekly and
imagine you have four years data points
how many data point you have maybe just
a little bit above 200 data points so
using this small data set to think all
this complex scenario it's really hard
to do the potential outcount analysis so
with think mm building an mm model is
more applicable in our
scenario and I hope I have persuad you
okay this is a good direction to go and
then now it's our favorite Parts I know
everyone must like math right no um
kiding uh so let explain about what is
our model a little bit right uh as I
mentioned again again uh we wanted to
decompose cells into base base and
incremental and in our case we consider
base coming from the trend and
seasonality and incremental except for
the marketing spending we also consider
the pricing strategy how we change the
price and some promotions Auto stock uh
microeconomics and some special event
like prand day or Thanksgiving Super
Bowl we could have build a linear
regression model to uh you know chose uh
model problem however we decided to take
one step further we uh adapt one of the
nonlinear transformation on on the
marketing spending from a paper proposed
by Google in 2017 and let's take a look
at how it
works so this is a detail of how we
could not transform the media CH uh
spending um it actually integrate two
common be uh consumer Behavior uh in our
uh modeling so the first Behavior we
call it Oso effect what does it mean uh
it says that after the first impression
or first clicks consumer might come back
later to execute your actual purchase so
your spending will happen when consumer
click your ads but your return might be
observed few days later so there's a lag
between this right and a second effect
we call it di diminishing returns is
it's it's a concept of that your
returnal investment is not linear growth
with your spending they will come to a
point of saturations where you spend
more but your return is actually smaller
you might see a minor change so we use
this uh nonlinear transformation to
consider more real worse scenario which
is something that linear model might
ignore
and perfect now come to the Hot Topic
hot Center of today's topic and I hope
you don't argue fight with each other if
you are standing in different Camp I
know usually frequen send the B and they
don't get along long
well um I personally used to be a very
loyalty frequences approach you know
nothing is better than just prepare
thousand of data fit in the model
waiting for hours and you have some sort
of magic Black Box helping you do all
the work um however uh you know since I
started to work in the industry most of
time you are dealing with data just with
hundreds of entes and you have to play
some Magic like it
work now I'm like a gradually towards Le
into um bent approach so for everyone
for anyone who does not have concept of
this tool approach here's a brief
comparison but the fundamental
difference lie into how you interpret
the probability right in the frequen
approach we assume that your unknown
parameters your coefficient they are
fixed number and all these events
observation they are random variables so
if you are doing the frequencies
approach you are finding this set of
parameters that can give you the best
prediction um of all of your
observations right so so you are finding
this optimal
combinations but bent approach assume
that your unknown variables or your
parameters they are random variables so
when you have observations you are
drawing a sample from each of the
distribution of your parameters and to
see whether you will produce an outcome
that is close to your um observation so
as you collect more data we will update
the distribution of each of the
parameters and hopefully you will
consistently produce something you know
close to your
observations so oops so now we have this
two approach let's try it uh uh both
approach and see uh which one any better
right so we started with building a
frequencies using a frequencies approach
and as I mentioned in the beginning is a
nonlinear regression problem not like
linear regression problem we have a
close Phone Solutions uh in nonlinear
regression we need to use some
humanistic algorithm to find the optimal
solution and you know one of the issue
that my happen well several issue might
happen is first it really depends on the
initial guess of the parameters right
now linear surveys might have many
different local optimals you might
converge to one of it so given different
initial G you might land it up different
optimal combination of parameters and
worst case sometime it might not even
find uh you know a solution or you might
not even converge so what follows are
intensive rounds of hyper parim tring
and it is very not very suitable in our
case and in this example is um it's a
toy case but it's similar to how we set
up the problems uh we could use a uh
curve F from CPI optimized module to
solve this
problem so now we move on to using
basent model uh there's a open source
package called lightweight MN is
basically help it's a framework help you
to easily set up mm analysis by Bas and
regressions however in our case we use
Jack and non pyro to build our custom
model and this two package grade they
give you a faster computational
implementation of mcmc sampling so it
make your learning model faster
basically and I I have to highlight here
one of the important step of B and
regression or B and learning is set up
the prior set up your prior distribution
basically how you assume all your
parameter distributed and I would say
this process uh require a lot of
collaboration with stakeholder and with
a domain expert so one of the example it
um we uh we we tried was using some
external data from collected from Amazon
marketing cloud and we uncover that 90%
of consumer actually converge within
seven days after the first click ads so
we use this distribution to fit the beta
distribution and use it as a prior to
the effect I just mentioned like at
stock effect so if you have a better
idea of your how your defense uh you
know variable contributes your model it
will really help you to converge or you
know learning a bit more accurate
model and as a result our model um
achieve a pretty good accuracy in terms
of predictions uh in the reporting area
the average arrow is around 3% but more
important we could now visualize how
different variables or drivers have
influenced our basine cells like we can
actually see uh certain Factor increase
or decrease sales from the basine and
lending into our observed
sales so now let's come back to our
initial motivation or initial questions
what do we want to do right we wanted to
identify the gap between attributed and
incremental sales or attributed return
and incremental return so what exactly
is attributed returns um here is example
if you search zero Pepsi you know what
you want to buy right and in the search
result you will get exactly same product
page one with a sponsor tag one result
so if you happen to click the first one
you will count it as attributed sales
even though it's actually for your
organic demander you really wanted to
buy zero Pepsi Zero so um so from our
model our prediction is that uh I don't
know what is this brand probably I made
that it's definitely not Pepsi but uh
one of the brand uh has 2.60 incremental
uh return on sales or return on spending
and attributed returnal spending high at
8.48 and both the incremental RI and
incremental contribution uh or almost
1/4 of attributed counterpart which
means more than 70% of reporting metrics
are actually organic so here is a huge
run of improve Improvement right we have
a lot of efficiency we could tackle and
if we look at next graph we could
leverage the ROI with the actual um uh
sales or actual contribution to see
identify the opportunity we in this
bubble for bubble chart the xais is a
incremental return on spending the Y AIS
is a incremental contribution and the
bubble size is the total sales of the
brand ideally we would like to see all
the bubble concentrate into the upper
right side where is that um we are
gaining as much as sales from brands
that have highi or we at least we wanted
the brand all moving towards that
direction especially this yellow bubble
and you can see here it has highest
return on investment however it seems
like we didn't invest enough so you only
have less than 4% of contribution so
it's definitely
uh a brand we could uh you know consider
differently and second analysis we did
is called due to analysis uh business
usually care about year-to-year
comparisons but with this model we are
able to break down the growth or um the
decrease by buckets in this example we
see the total sales growth uh grew 46%
for 20 21 to
2022 and if if we Analyze This 46% of
growth we found that majority of growth
coming from the Bas sales uh the demand
you know natural growth and the
inflation we know like 2022 is inflation
crazy and is seem is driving a lot of
sales for this particular brand but
besides this two uncontrollable variable
we see that because we are maybe
spending more we getting additional 4%
positive sale from sponsor search
campaign and we have 6% Positive Growth
because of our better pricing
strategy however on the F side uh it
seems like we lost 5% of a gross
opportunity because of maybe reduction
of the promotions and in the future we
could layer the profitability data to
further analyze how we could better you
know put our promotion strategy to
minimize this this uh uh opportunity
lost and great now we have our model
buil and um we have the model put into
production is that it like we could just
sign off the project
easy no of course
not yeah so um building setting out not
model just a very first step of the
whole project and why is that there's a
lot of Reason um the first things uh
especially for this project is
explainability right so you don't want
to see that outo stock is giving your
business a positive self you you cannot
fulfill 100% of of your order but you're
still getting more uh getting more sales
right it doesn't make sense you you
don't want to to see negative uh impact
of your sales because of you're putting
you know marketing campaign at least 10
0% not negative so in this case we need
to be very careful to choose how do you
scale your features usually you would do
standardization and moving your feature
around normally distributed around zero
right but that will bring in negative
value of your featur when you fed uh
such a model you might create the SC
like autosa give you a positive impact
so we need to be very creative of how do
you uh fure engineering your different
variables and the second is outliers
outliers will impact your train
seasonality um uh estimations in this
case we're seeing a lot of autosock
happening here and some spike that might
not even correlate some holidays random
Spike we need to detect them and uh do
some special treatment either smoothing
smoothing it out or uh imputed them uh
by better value right um and we built
several outlier detection model to you
know to acture uh effort uh in the
feature engineering uh
step as next one is the price designed
as I mentioned in uh the basent approach
uh it's very important building setting
up such a model except for the outa
analysis we are also looking for data to
better understand the price elasticity
on different products and hopefully we
could use some product category right
the different back size different brands
different categories might give you
different reaction between the price or
uh campaign or sponsor search so we
could do build some hierarchical
learning to regularize your um products
uh your Model Behavior by their
categorical
features and next one is an interesting
uh uh Discovery in this Pro projects so
uh we know multicolinearity usually is a
big problem if you are trying to fit the
regression problem especially when
you're using the frequencies approach
you would say discover whether you have
feature that is correlation with each
other and just select one and in this
case we know that price and inflation
they for sure will have some correlation
but we really wanted to keep both of
them how do we do that um so in our case
um we've discover that using the Basin
approach is actually helping you to
reduce the multicol sity effect so there
is a toy case um we use this twep
training the first steps we will exclude
one of the factors and just fed the
model let's say price and inflation I
will exclude the inflation just fit the
model with just price and then I will
get this number uh get the mean fitted
by the first model and I use it as a
prior into the second model fitting
which is con including both features and
it turns out it can actually help you to
learn the model better so in this case
real value is two Z I think it's pretty
small but the real value is two 0.5 and
three of three uh uh coefficients and in
the end we learn uh 1.95 Z 39 a little
bit off but with a you know with there's
a confident level you could look at C
and 299 but if you look at using the um
fre frequences approach we see the P
value is super high which means like we
cannot really trust our model it's not
really you know giving you something
significant um so we uh I think this is
another um design we need to keep in
mind when we are building um you know
mmm um the next uh yeah and and the next
thing I wanted to call out is this hyper
parameter training uh in the Productions
usually you need to have some set of
metrics to decide what is your best
model and in this case just looking at a
predict dition arrow is trivia like it
doesn't do anything of course it will
give you a idea how the model work
however it doesn't tell you the full
picture of how you how is your
coefficient how is your Roi so we have
to design a set of rule either business
rule base or other metrics to evaluate
the coefficient that we learned in our
production environment and it usually is
a um you know iterative process with
between data science and our
stakeholder so um so all right we are
coming to the end of this use case and I
there are three main takeaways I would
like to uh like you to take home today
the first one is um frequen approach
usually provide you a faster and simple
way to learn the data pattern however by
an approach give you uh the flexibility
to integrate your prior experiment
experience and domain expertise into
your modeling efforts and it usually
works better when the data sets model
and a second takeaway is the
explainability is a key when you're
doing such a model marketing mix
modeling and we could utilize a clever
way of fion engineering to boost the
explainability and last one this never
uh is a one-time solution it's going to
be a iterative process uh between
different part of um business and and um
sometimes more like arts and science so
does this means we are never going to
end this
project
maybe um so call back to uh for everyone
who you know stay from last session you
might already you know agree with me
that answering a doing a correlation
analysis might not enough to answer a
CAO problems so and you you know there's
a lot of challenge like especially for
scenario that's never happened in the
past how could we solve potentially
solve this questions right so one of the
idea is maybe we could build some
simulation system by bringing by
bringing different more augmented data
set right we could create some um more
of change we could uh create some
transition magic to know how consumer
will react to your decision in different
way and you could use simulation system
to test how robust your model is and
hopefully we could launch sort of
experiment or measurement to test your
model to validate whether your
hypothesis is correct so yeah maybe it
will never end uh but at least we could
get in close
there yeah and that's all I have today
thank
you
yeah